over here and we have in move one
setting up the initial
my what is very very important about
that is as we are going to use the
spiral rotating crosses and again that
is key that is key to iida that you
spiral rotate the yin yangong axis
because that is the technology of self
at the energetic level uh that is the
whole thing of what non-c contestation
means in in the words jiujitsu it means
that uh we're going to lose the
antagonistic or the dichotomous
relationship between yin and yang how do
you do that you rotate them just like
you do your your Tom den and when you do
that that the magic happens why because
everything returns back to the the
moment of creation to the the moment of
the doubt okay that's what we're doing
so nobody can tell me that we shouldn't
be spiral rotating the yin Yong axis so
even if cha Sensei himself told me no no
no I'm yongyong clashing and I'm just
hitting the stick I would say you're
wrong and you're wrong you should do it
like I'm doing it okay
so if you look and eventually you'll
figure this out the spiral rotating that
we're doing
because of the nature of the two weapons
and the angles that were're at and
because he's attempting to defang the
snake he's not really over
penetrating my spiral rotating of this
cross is very very
small meaning I'm not painting big
circles well the only way I can spiral
rotate another lever weap weapon
especially a blade uh on very small
small circles is if we're at the end of
the weapons if we're in the middle of
the weapons you got to make bigger
circles to spiral rotate the uh Yin Yong
axis so that makes sense though
martially speaking because he's trying
to use a bladed weapon to the best of
its ability and that would be uh and
it's shorter that would be stay at the
edge of his weapon okay and defang the
snake instead so this makes Marshal
sense and this makes mechanical sense
and when it comes to move one it is very
important that you set up that my and
that my is we're at the edges the the
the distal ends of everyone's weapon
we're not in the middle of the weapons
you may see some forms where we hanging
out like this and I would say I would I
would never do that just like if he's a
taller he's a taller Fighter for example
uh don't throw your sword down and let's
just have this hand in your fighting
position it doesn't do me any good to
fight within his jab range because I
cannot hit him because he's taller than
me so I can't stand then where I could
jab him because by the time I get there
he would have already jabbed me so the
person with longer range I have to fight
outside of his range not not inside my
range okay and you have to figure out
techniques of closing the Gap so one
might be uh as as he throws that jab
boom I'll just smack the jab down very
much like defanging the snake Okay and
then I would close okay so I'm not a fan
of this I know there's lots of like
shindo techniques where they like that
but to me that doesn't make sense okay
uh it's it's trying to do something else
than what cha Sensei forms are doing so
we're out out of range he's out of my
range okay and so when we close when he
goes up it's important that I stay when
he touches my weapon that he's at the
end of my weapon okay not here in the
middle of my weapon okay and that has to
do where you
start up boom he's at the edge okay so
let's key that in and then uh we'll go
from
there okay so uh if we look at some
things so let's say he he brings his
weapon up okay and let's say he had uh
ski
potential like he's going to hit me so
remember I described it as he's just
taking a uh a counter position to where
my weapon is okay but let's say he has
ski potential stay there please then he
would have to be way closer to me and
that weapon would have to penetrate my
Target because touching me in the face
here is not ski potential just just like
if he poked me in the ribs this is not
ski potential he has to get way closer
than that to have enough penet
penetration no different than on a punch
so when I'm here like this and I'm just
kissing the surface of this that's not a
punch my punches are in here where they
can penetrate through the Target or if I
was kicking the target I don't kiss the
target I have to be able to penetrate
the Target and you can see how much
closer boom I have to be in order to do
that okay so same thing
here so if he was to do a ski to my
face first move he'd have to be here
does that make sense okay and then he
would have to do Sugi to get there so
you get to shuffle backwards one two now
put the Joe down and that's where he
would have to be standing for us to do
the form okay for that to be a ski well
he's never going to get there cuz he's
in my range
okay um so there's no way it's a ski
okay so we didn't make it a ski okay and
now if we go back and he sticks that up
there and here I'm trying to understand
the M because this is move one setting
up the initial mod if he's just here do
you see and he does zashi back one two
and he puts the weapon down now we're
kind of in a little better area do do
you guys get that okay so when he comes
back to here now when I do isido ten con
if I spiral rotated out of this you see
though my head goes back I don't know
camera if you can see that but I have to
shift my weight onto the back leg so I
do a single Pivot Point I've already got
some distance do you see where where it
is right here like 2 in I I shift my
weight I've now got like a foot almost
and then when I turn I got another 2 in
and then when I step back I got even
more okay and so if I have my S where
where all this is going what I'm going
to do is again not try to get down there
like this I'm now going to use the back
part of his spine that I was correcting
him on that spine I'm going to use to
bring that down okay so that's what I'm
trying to do and where should I do it
the at the lighter part of the weapon at
the end of the weapon okay so he's there
I follow rotate IEP step back and then
this is where I'm at and then that's
what I bring down
okay
again
one boom HP this is where I would be
bring that down bringing him in and that
is my target so that was it stay there
please this was it that's all I needed
to hit it with the cutting portion of my
bhead boom and I would cut it off
okay so it's not a ski where he passes
my
head and then I come here and then I go
here okay and this is very important
because the flip side of of the setting
up the correct m is not only the
Mechanics for the weapons work but all
weapons are going to have a m where you
do not motivate or instigate the
personal weapons coming into it because
it's here where anybody that's fighting
for the life would just start grappling
me cuz he's going to get cut he's going
to get cut okay so you have to stay in a
Range as we go Bo let's go you have to
stay in a Range that it doesn't make
sense for him to try to Grapple me
because it's going to be cut by the time
he closes to that range okay so that's
the flip side of the initial range one
you want to be at the end of the levers
those are the lightest thing lightest
part of the weapon that we're going to
spiry or rotate and two you have to not
go you have to not be in a place where
he's going to Grapple but instead he has
to use his weapon okay try it again all
right so to justify this m where I'm at
the tips the thing I said is that you're
you have to spiral rotate the cross
there's just it's not iido if you're not
doing that okay but I said that that
spiral rotation is going to be very
small very short and the reason being is
a principle called the outer rim my
weapons can never go outside my outer
rim and they can't go outside of his
Outer Rim because my weapon must always
be oriented towards him okay so what
this means if you just look at his body
he's got a width to him and the outer
rib goes uh on the lateral margin is the
shoulders and then on the top margin
it's where the the curvature of the head
doesn't go to the top okay so uh what I
mean by curvature of the head about here
if I hit him it glances off it's where I
don't glance off anymore so it's
somewhere around here is the top of the
outer rim not the top of the head okay
and then it's going to be the bottom of
the pelvis in this same area where I
don't glance off underneath but it
displaces him it's somewhere right above
the penis bladder area you're in the
bladder area okay that's the bottom and
it's egg
shape so my weapon should never Point
outside that outer rim for the same
reason that now the lateral spine is
open to his downward attacks especially
if he's in jodon position okay so when
St there when we do this move this first
move you can't bring your the tip of
your Joe the distal end outside that
outer rim and then
in but you also can't bring it up
because it ca straight up because it
causes tension in the right shoulder as
you do this which can also be exploited
by him
so I'm going to make a circle with my
right hand to lower the proximal end but
I have to keep my distl end no further
to my left his right than his right
shoulder so it goes up this
way not this
way within his shoulder
R within his shoulder R
Bo okay that's going to keep us where we
need to be and make sense because as I
said if I were to go outside he goes to
jodon and if I go outside he should just
attack the arm it's right there
okay so you have to make sure you're
doing that so that he is motivated to
stay at the distal end and not go right
for the cut
so that he is motivated to spiral rotate
the yyong axis okay if you look at
everyone else what they do and I'm going
to have to show you the wrong way you
bring your sword
up and when you step back just hit it
horizontal down here like that
okay come
back so he brings the sword up I want to
make sure you could do it you step back
and you bring it horizontal down okay
come back and hence my weapon was going
up his sword is going down it's a Yong
Yong Clash we're just hitting sticks
okay and if I'm strong enough to do this
when he goes down it's his weapon that
would move not my weapon that would move
okay so he has to do like keto and he
has to spiral rotate the cross and to do
that he has to First fill the in space
to the Y to the Yong adhesion point and
hence his first move is not the
immediate hitting of my weapon down but
that make a cross on the inside of the
weapon the Yang side is the top of my
Joe spine but on the inside lateral side
it's Yin space and that's where he
penetrates closes the distance and makes
contact so we're going to go slow so
he's going up I'm coming up and he first
this is too sharp you guys see that it's
too sharp your two this
way and if I was strong enough boom it's
your weapon that moves okay so
instead you should just reach to make a
cross with no movement of my weapon
don't move it this is where he should be
okay so let's let me show that cuz he
does he didn't have that
skill he didn't have the skill cuz he's
learning the majority of people don't
have the skill so they do something that
is not iido and then probably wouldn't
work
anyways because we're not understanding
the spiraling cross okay so when I go in
and his weapon comes up my movement goes
here right
here there's
no pressure do you see that I just reach
to touch it and once I reach to touch it
if you if I hold it right there I now
have my Yin Andy Yang axis okay and now
I'm going to rotate
it and now I've reconciled his upward
energy okay and that's what I've done
and then I can have this angle of attack
where I take this complimentary angle
from the I
adhesion through I won the fight okay so
the point here is how to understand the
spiral rotating cross first move is make
the inside reach the inside establish
the XY AIS and then rotate it okay so
that's what I'm going to show again on
the first move boom nice and slow boom
no pressure now I have it and now I
rotate the cross then I follow the
complimentary angle in from the adhesion
into the
weapon up there's the cross rotate the
cross follow the compliment angle in
from the
ad boom
boom
no
pressure okay move
four I the and going over the rotating
cross on move four but we have to bring
up another Marshal concept and that is
that my defense is made up minimum of
two things my angle of deflection so
however I'm dealing uh with his line of
attack and not let it follow me in the
second aspect of my defense my angle of
deviation okay so some simple things and
not necessarily iido if here's his punch
my angle of deflection would be my
inward carry and is traveling to my left
okay and my angle of deviation is going
to be my step out to the side okay and
the general rule is that they must
complement each other so if I have a
inward Parry then my footwork must take
me to the outside if the punch goes one
way I go the other way okay all right so
here we go and when it comes to move
four I I have to do that okay so he goes
up I go down and he's going to cut my
arm okay first let me fix his mistake
there you still have that outer
rib and you cannot Point your weapon
down right okay so let's fix
that again the rule on the weapon is
your weapon has to always be pointed at
the adversary so I cannot point it over
here we know already that that'll open
up the lateral spine but I cannot point
it to the ground either okay then the
weapon is not in the fight the weapon
has to always be in the fight and for
the weapon to be in the fight it must be
pointed at you at all times okay so when
we do that move boom I cannot go here
because the weapon is now not in the
fight and his weapon is actually more in
fight than my weapon okay so my atos
that I do it can't go past boom parallel
to the ground all of the downward the
drop cannot go past parallel if I wanted
more drop then I have to lower my stance
but I cannot point the tip down on any
atoui movements okay so again we're here
there's my rotating cross and the weapon
stays parallel to the ground that's all
I need for this movement is the cut
right there okay okay so don't push it
down like
that and we'll end up giving the same
correction here eventually but I want to
go and talk about what I want to talk
about so angle deviation angle
deflection stay
there here he goes get us there all
right make the cross and get on top
before you get your attack stay
there I ended up deviating this way
okay here there's the cross and you're
going to rotate it okay I'm going to
move you're going to rotate it I'm going
to move inside this way
okay if I come over here stay there
there's no deviation going the other way
I move to the right no deviation going
to the left and this is why when I go to
ski he would be following the sword back
in from his cut and you'd get
killed what my ski did is added
deviation following the rules that I
move his weapon to the left because I'm
going to the right
okay so we go one two
first here reach out and make a cross
rotate the cross okay and that drop that
I have there
I'm going to start moving to the right
because he's going to start coming back
so as he comes back I move to the to the
right
okay we'll do it again one slower please
he goes one he comes back in I move to
the
right one
up two three four swing your sword
please
okay so I'm going to the right that's my
angle deviation going go slow for this
we'll just make
contact we already rotated let's
say go really
slow here's that
cross I'm going to move it
over with me as he's cutting and you can
see what it's doing I'm getting closer
to the end of the
weapons and so I brought my Joe if you
pay attention maybe it's over
here the tip of my Joe is INS is right
on the edge of his outer rim no like
this over here like
that and then I rotate this little cross
on my ski and I keep rotating it as
we're going back and that's how I get my
angle deflection the other way and I
open up the target
here it is very tempting otherwise
everyone would be doing it and I think
if s say wanted you to do that he would
have done it and everyone would be doing
it it's very tempting to go here stay in
place and move this weapon like that and
that's not what I'm
doing you have to use a complimentary of
deviation with the angle of deflection
so as we go one and he starts to come
into the
hand I have to move to get my hand out
of the way boom boom
boom I call this mistake painting with
the distal
end I stay still and I move it around in
the circle there's no angle deviation
there if you watch your back hand is
making these big circles as well as your
front hand if I'm doing it correctly
it's just here boom
boom and if you pay attention go back
stay there go
back hey fill the
space and then he went around the y
space I'm going to do the same thing to
him he has the Y Line cuz he has the
atos I have the yin space I'm going to
rotate stay there don't Shuffle in again
and now I've rotated the cross and I
keep it rotating past that way
boom so look for the cross to rotate
sh
slower okay try again just explaining
the rotating cross I have to fill the in
space or allow to be in the in space in
this case and then I rotate the Y yin
and AIS I'm now the one doing the atage
oh bring your weapon back up
again and that same rule would
apply so from the atos contact back I
cannot go he cuts I cannot point my
weapon down it has to never break the
parallel line because it has to be
pointing at him up it goes boom and
Bo and
again
boom here we go so here's a drill um
where I'm going to totally relax at the
as the book in and um I'm going to
almost
co-generate this is how I'll describe it
at first cogenerate the iky but really
if if I just release and relax the sword
will stick to him I don't have to do
anything um and that's what we're trying
to do okay so we start we're not going
to compete or go fast cuz it'll trigger
the fear pride and ignorance and we're
trying to cogenerate the iy the spiral
rotating crosses so I one I reach out
without pushing his weapon and I just
let it drop move he
goes and I would like for you to focus
on my grip and how loose it is okay
don't point it down
this
okay let's go this drill that we're
doing that I'm trying to get them to do
is really a sensitivity drill but it's
also it's a release drill okay you could
I you could look it any way so as Karen
was saying and and I described to her
it's like it's a feeling okay it's a
feeling a we're talking about gaining
sensitivity okay
um and you become more sensitive when
your ego when the fear pride and
ignorance the three the three evils the
three demons are not pling you you
become more sensitive okay there's
there's a a correlation between that the
demon possession of those three demons
and awareness or his absence so the more
those demons possess you the less aware
you are so vice versa then this is about
becoming sensitive okay becoming aware
becoming sensitive so the drill that I'm
doing is uh as as we go on with the
drill is like I can I know where that
weapon is I don't ever overshoot it do
you see and I know that that's y if I go
any further that would be y I'm
sensitive to that and I am sensitive to
where that Yin spot is on the back of
your spine you see so it doesn't take
any weight it doesn't take any weight
and I'm sensitive to the complimentary
angle so I can stay there I don't ever
would never do that you see I feel it
and the weapon goes so as he goes and
I'm sensitive to what his weapon is I
can stay you're going to send it around
you're lost yes okay woo if I could get
through a demonstration okay so I'm here
here comes the cut and I know where the
yin space is in the in the circle as
this cross is
rotating because the way that I defend
myself is I rotate the cross he rotated
that's how you do it every single time
in the set okay so if I come flying off
of which I will if I go y against your
spiral rotating of the cross I will get
pinned the weapon will go fine off
you'll get your angle deflection and
boom I'm going to get skewer but if I'm
fine when you if I understand that as
you spir rotate the cross you actually
now put me in the in where I'm supposed
to be to again spir rotate the cross
okay and so I just have to be
comfortable with that and I have to feel
where is the in space what's it feel
like it feels like nothing I don't I
shouldn't feel anything I'm just hanging
out and letting everything happen Okay
so if I am doing that correctly and I
come here and I gain that feeling as he
goes I'm going to be right in the area
to do it all again right here so I do
the same thing again the cross I go to
the yin line here he go he's trying to
go here he penetrates make sure you ENT
please he penetrates and there's that
move pull and I've cut it off
again so I'm here I need
him to rotate it so that I get Stu on
the other side he goes Bo and there it
is poop and
cut again I'm going to I I want us to do
it here with the releasing in mind so
we're not going to go fast F and I'm
going to try not to hold this thing
because if I if the sword is in the in
space I don't have to grip the sword and
if it's in here to you I don't have to
uh grip the sword and I don't have to
give it any input because I'm in the y
space so that's that's why I do this
okay and it helps gain sensitivity
because when I flex like this I can't
tell what is going on okay so one boom
pop boom
boom
and you if you pay attention I did that
spir rotation on the on my left side
boom and I'm going to do it on the right
side and it's the same
strategy
as soon as you ski you should just come
back in right you it's not a matter of
coming fast it's not hanging out in the
back stance it's a matter of not just
getting r that
pause there you
go getting burn more your tension
any of you pay attention go back I am
going to the left the sword is going the
Joe's going to the right so I have
paired up again angle deviation with
angle of
deflection same thing over here so slow
same thing over here I go to the left
sword goes to the right
okay sorry I go to the right sword it
goes to the left okay so angle
deviations go opposite angles with with
the angle deflection one two 3
four and it's very much like iido and
that he runs into just like I would run
into
that he's going to run into my arm
cut okay let's try it's very tempting to
go back to the other go back to the
other thing okay
um not spiral rotating just hitting
sticks okay so it's very tempting to
just go here get it instead of stick up
please instead of adhering on his on his
energy that's coming forward adhering it
and then rotating that energy okay it's
very tempting like ah why do I have to
do that oh when you're fighting someone
that's really trying to kill you or is
much stronger than you then you realize
why you have have to do it okay and then
the same thing here is he comes around
and he goes it's very tempting to just
go like that do you get it and you don't
want to do that pay attention to the yin
space that is going to be generated and
I should try to fill that Yin space okay
so as uh you're here pop good show
around then he brings the weapon back
there's no reason why I should come back
and wait for that weapon to go I don't
know where that weapon is going to go DC
at this point I can't tell if that
thing's going to go jodon Chon or gidon
you get it or shci or whatever so what
you would do is let's rewind the film a
little okay eventually I'm on the other
side of his of this weapon over here so
you always follow it into its
source that's what you're doing here do
you get it okay so if I follow it into
the source I fill the in space and now I
obey the angle deviation angle
deflection rule so I'm going to move
this way as you start to ski and that's
how I make that initial cross I don't
leave it all open and hit it and I don't
let it get all the way out here and then
I hit it
okay so let me show the mistake that I'm
trying to get you to understand one two
it's very similar to this one three four
five do
no instead we'll go slower so you can
see it boom pop boom follow it you get
it I'm going to follow it in
okay because I'm going to adhere to the
inside of it as long as I can okay one
two you're a little out range boom hop
boom hop follow it in then I follow it
back up okay so if I followed it
in there's no way I'm going to be here
and wait for it I I'm going to be
vertical to it do you see that just like
the other one so as you come out that's
where I sucked up to it and as you start
to finish that's where the atos comes
and that's where my cut
comes see like this is vertical the in
axis is up here not over here okay
boomp same thing here follow it in boom
then is the cut okay try to obviously we
went ahead from the releaseing
sensitivity drill and we did do um we
introduced move five okay is it five I'm
sorry
six
um but I wanted to get to the e of move
s the makios on the Joe and because I
still want to do the releasing Dr okay
and I'm trying to give you more
understanding of what is going on um in
the book and I allowed my grip in the
releasing drill to be very loose I'm
barely touching it in the Joe I'm going
to just hold one end okay and here's why
this works if I I am adhering and
letting him move me from
y if I'm adhering to his Joe at the
cross when he SP rotates it I should
stay
adhere and when I spir rotated back from
my yin to back to my y I don't need to
hold the Jo the cross is holding the Jo
up okay so that's what we're going to do
uh so as I do this part I don't have any
I don't use the other hand he
goes pop and I move inside he did that
to me again and you can see that I'm
holding his weapon is holding it up okay
and I go and he goes and then his weapon
holds it up again and here is go back
here's where makios is he go he goes in
where you have the okay but for our
sensitivity drill we're just going to
work one hand he goes up boom boom
boom
boom home and this is where we'll just
stop there okay and that is where the
seat of M push again
one try to
more I don't know what's going on why do
it keep going around bring it to the top
top your head top of your head and then
straight down then rotate it
good why am might SC up come
on work together one Slow Down slow down
good rotate it slow down let it rotate
good boom let it rotate
good again slow up wait
give the opening to your face let the
weapon get up and now you go
boom I let it rest boom I let it
rest there it
Isom
boom
boom okay try
that
even more open them up open them up open
them up open them
up
totally flat extended
fingers good